coming from a baptist background that
right you're a christian baptist and
christians obviously have this deep love
for jesus but now just to touch upon
this you love would you say you love
jesus more now as a muslim absolutely
before absolutely because
we already know there's a lot of
additions and subtractions
in the bible that exist today top
theologists
pastors ministers all around the world
a firmness
even if the followers of this you know
practice faith
deem it to be untrue the reality of it
is those who are most versed in
understanding the text that's present
today that there's been alterations
there's been things taken out there's
been things added so on and so forth but
the one thing that remains exclusive all
throughout the body
is god's right to be worshipped alone
without any partners without any
interceding
and then the messengership of jesus
you know i'm saying becomes something
very very significant
and
you know gravitational for the muslim
because now
if you came from a christian background
and you had your confusion or your rep
you know your uh your doubts about
whether jesus is worthy to be worshiped
or followed
right
whether he's worthy to be worshiped
or is he worthy to be followed because
that's the confusion
his existence is not the confusion
we're not confused about his existence
you know saying but growing up as a
baptist my confusion was whether or not
he is to be worshiped or is he to be
followed
because we used to say statements like
what would christ do
so these are statements saying that okay
whatever he did i should follow him
right
because you can't say to the one that
you worship
what would he do
i don't know you know saying if my
intention is to worship but if my
intention is to follow him then i have
to investigate what he did what actions
he performed or what he implemented when
adversity hit in order for me to follow
him so
becoming a muslim
it becomes abundantly clear
that he was one of the most beloved
messages to allah
you know and i can't be a muslim
unless i believe in jesus
i can't be a muslim unless i believe in
his immaculate conception
i can't be a muslim unless i believe
that he's the word of god meaning he's
the manifestation of the statement be
and there he was amen brother not the
walking talking believing speaking word
he's the manifestation of the statement
be
and there he was in the womb of a virgin
so now all is clarity only increases
your inclination to this beloved
messenger and knowing that today even as
a muslim i'm following his methodology
you know saying so now my
love and appreciation for him has grown
and multiplied
you know and this is what brings a lot
of christians to islam
you know
outside of other other things that allah
choose to change the hearts
but when it comes to like a studious
perspective
or
you know analyzing you know saying
certain
doubts like i said or confusion
this clarity is what makes people
who come from this previous belief
come to islam
yeah let's touch upon that tohit because
as a christian a lot of christians you
know they follow along you know they
come in jump in sunday
and go through all the musical you know
instruments everybody's dancing slings
you know singing clapping and then you
know when it comes down to this trinity
right people are confused right but you
know my father died it did it you know
my parents and i'm just kind of blending
in you know what i mean absolutely so
you went through that also i'm sure and
you know a lot of people but when you
come down to the clarity of islam you
know for the person that this this is
the thing that did it for me really one
of the things along with the evidence
quran has the evidence that it's from
the divine it's not blind faith right if
you prophecies miracles there's no way
that this book can come from a human
being you know it's from the creator so
now when you look at you know the pure
monotheism right because the trinity is
confusing what you know like i worship
the father son holy ghost how did this
when you learned the pure monotheism of
islam well the thing is
the quran it affirms everything
every book that was that preceded
so
now there's a bridge
you know saying it's not like you have
to discard
completely
everything that proceeded
that monotheistic command remains
in the torah it remains and the gospel
remains in a song still there still
there
i tell people you know like this is the
thing
when i have conversations with
christians
it's a lot more easier for me because i
was a christian yes so depending on
what's the basis of a person's belief
is it something that's been handed down
then the dialogue that you have with
this individual has to be very very
careful
because you're not offending their
belief
when it comes down to it you're
offending the one they got it from
understand
it's like you're calling my grandmother
a liar
this is where the defensiveness comes
it's not like you're using legislation
to defend what you believe you're
defending the one that you entrusted
with your belief which have faith
and
me contradicting that is as if i'm
calling them a liar
so this is where the you know the the
aggression comes in the budding and the
argumentation and so on and so forth so
when i speaking to someone who this is
their plight i kind of tread like
but i enjoy having conversations with
people who actually read the bible
because then it becomes easy to point
out all the exclusive statements that
still remain hero israel the lord thy
god is one
yeah love your lord thy god with all
your might with all your strength with
all your heart with all your soul
not one third for mary one third for the
holy ghost one third for the traveling
saint patrick one third for not no he
said oh
that's tohit yeah that means singling
out allah
or singling out god with all of these
different characteristics and the lord's
prayer has islam in it or our father who
in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done this is
islam absolutely
and people don't really understand the
king's english anyway
because i'm gonna tell you there is a
verse
when i was young i used to be in bible
study well you used to also be in bible
study yeah i wasn't sure you did you did
your homework
i was in church six days a week six days
a week as a kid wow i left church
because of the actions of the people but
what always remain is those exclusive
statements
and some of the misconceptions that i
wanted clarity for for example there's a
verse
in the bible that tells you call no man
on earth your father
but then we have a command
that says honor thy mother and father
i'm a child that's confusing
right
because dads don't get nicknames yeah
when you're acknowledging who they are
in totality you're my father right so if
you're my father how could i follow this
verse that commands me to call no man on
earth my father
so now the investigation leads to the
king's english the king's english
father and son
linguistically in the king's english
means servant and master
so now if i convert the word into master
now it makes sense call no man on earth
your master
now i can honor my father
you know saying it's a little things
like this
is what get took him word for
verbatim as to be the word
but
thou shalt not place no other god before
me
that's to heed
right
the word god linguistically means object
of worship so now thou should not place
no other object or worship before me
that becomes clear to me now
there's another verse in isaiah it says
you may know me and know that i am he
before me no god was formed
nor should there be any after me
for i am the lord and beside me there is
no savior
so now that clarifies who my savior is
the one who created me is the only one
that can save me
not jesus not muhammad not because that
was in the old testament yes so this is
before the advent of jesus so now we
cannot take
this infinite wisdom and knowledge of
their creator and say that he made a
mistake
you know what later on you know i mean i
changed my mind
he's going to be your lord and savior
now the only way to justify that would
be saying
that jesus is god
that'll be the only way you can justify
that because once you have an exclusive
statement well god is telling you that
besides me there is no savior
the only way you'll be able to justify a
created
being
to be your savior
is if allah
gives his divinity
relinquishes it and gives it to his
creation that would be your only way to
justify it
when you would go into the churches you
go in different churches you go to a
greek orthodox church they got a picture
of jesus certain color
asian church you have jesus oh yeah yeah
when i was growing up i seen him with
afro get out yeah jesus out of half that
jesus had an aphrodisiac
yeah i mean afro afro pick they had
spanish you know puerto ricans they had
jesus you know jesus he had the nice you
know curly hair like so i mean this is
this is this is a symbol of hope
and belief and so on and so forth and
i'm not here to attack anyone no no no
no no it's just that through my
experiences
i've learned as a person who wasn't
searching for religion after i removed
myself
from the actions of the people of the
church yeah and what i learned
from the bible or whatever
misconceptions i had i could never get
answers i would ask because i mean if
i'm here present every day i'm studying
i think i deserve the right to get
clarity when i'm running into certain
things that are you know
not clear
so that became a trial for me and then
like i said later on in life to be able
to find islam and be able to
find that everything that was revealed
before is the firm in this book
i would have never been able to have a
conversation with a jewish person today
like i can i would never have an
opportunity or ability to have a
conversation with a learned christian
person
whether they're preacher theologists
whatever i can have dialogue with all
these people
no one can say that like now they're
listening someone's watching said man
this guy wasn't a real christian
well if they say that i mean we're all
entitled to an opinion you know i'm
saying but
i don't think that anyone that followed
jesus during his messengership were
considered christians they were
considered muslims
they were considered
one who submits to the will of god
that's what muslim means it's a
universal term yeah that concept was
there yeah no one calls people to follow
jesus moses knights no one calls people
who follow abraham ibrahimians like
these terms never came until good song
until the advent of
a sub new medium jesus the son of mary
as we acknowledge him yeah you know
so now
god doesn't have a skin color skin tone
a nationality a zip code and islam is
clear
now this is we just did something this
is the living miracle see like we didn't
plan this pla you know this is like
you're reciting that you're not arab
this is what the language the sister
language to arabic aramaic you have it
preserved
so you can go ahead and uh go with
someone who's memorized the entire quran
and they can go ahead just like we did
with the whole back and forth one of the
greatest
miracles that we have in our possession
today
and i'm gonna kind of say this in
closing is that
if we were to discard
every book
that's possessed
by
a jew
a christian
and the muslims
the muslims will be able to reproduce
another quran in hours
because there's hundreds of millions of
muslims who memorize the quran from
front to back children nine years old
memorize the quran from front to back
if you were to remove a single hadaka a
single vowel
we would know
through reciters
you know what i'm saying and people you
know who memorize the question yeah
those other books would be lost
they'll be lost
because even if there is a single
soul that memorizes the whole torah from
front to back
it would never be to the magnitude of
the muslims because we recite the quran
every day
amazing every single day